من السينما ومن اهم ليالي السينما التي
تنطلق بعد الساعات عاما بعد عام تتراجع
مشاهدات حفل الاوسكار بصوره دراماتيكيه
النسخه الماضيه جذبت 16 مليون مشاهد فقط
وهو رقم كاد ان يكون اقل لولا صفعه ويل
سميث التاريخيه قبل تسع سنوات فقط وتحديدا
في حفل السلف الشهير شاهد العرض المباشر
اكثر من 43 مليون شخص ولوقف النزيف
الاكاديميه تستهدف الشباب بشكل خاص في
نسخه العام وهي الفئه الاقل اهتماما
بمتابعه العرض فلاول مره يبث المهرجان
خطابات الفوز في اكبر ست فئات وعلى تيك
توك وفيسبوك ومن التغييرات ايضا ستعرض
لقطات من خلف الكواليس للنجوم على منصات
التواصل والاهم مهرجان بلا سجاده حمراء
تقرير التالي يتعرف على هدايا مرشح
الاوسكار سواء فازوا بالتمثال الذهبي اول
او لا مع الزميل رافي بوصيه
[موسيقى]
260 الف دولار هي قيمه حقيبه هدايا
الاوسكار لهذا العام من مستحضرات العنايه
بالبشره مرورا بخدمات التجميل وحتى
الرحلات الفاخره وسواء فازوا بالاوسكار ام
لا ستكون الهديه من نصيب 26 مرشحا في فئات
افضل اداء واخراج
[موسيقى]
اثمن ما في الحقيبه رحله فاخره الى كندا
بقيمه اربعين الف دولار ورحله الى ساحل
ايطاليا بقيمه تسعه الاف دولار
[موسيقى]
كل عام لا تقل قيمه هديه الاوسكار عن
التسعين الف دولار بلغت اقصاها عام 2020
حين تجاوزت
225,000 دولار بينما لا تتجاوز قيمه
التمثال الذهبي ال 400 دولار رافب عصيان
لوس انجلوس
[موسيقى]
التحدث عن توقعات الاوسكار اهلا بك يا
رافي منورنا في الاستوديو صباح الخير طيب
رافي نتحدث عن توقعات الفائزين في الاحد
في الحدث الاهم سينمائيه الحفل الاوسكار
في دورته الخامسه نبدا اولا عن الفئه
الرئيسيه الفئات الرئيسيه او اولا شنو
فيلمك المفضل هالسنه كان
انا اقول لك
الفيلم اللي حبيته حبيت
ترشح كتير ما كتير يعني
لانه كسر الارقام
مع بعض
ارقام قياسيه في الاراده
كبيره في لوسكاد بنسخته الخامسه والتسعين
وانما
اللي هو
ممكن ان يحصد بالاسكار لهذا العام عن فئه
افضل فيلم اما افضل ممثله هي شبه محسومه
افضل ممثل هي بين برندن فيسر من ويلز
وايضا اللي هو اللي قام بدور الفيسبريسلي
فانا اعتقد عاده
ال 10,000 شخص هم دائما يميلون الاشياء
لها علاقه بالبايوغرافي فلهذا السبب اعتقد
شوي اعلى من
فريزر اما الافلام الانيميشن شبه محسومه
لفيلم بينوكيو يعني فاز بكل جوائز اللي
تسبق حفل الاوسكار اما الممثلين اللي بدور
مساعد الممثل بدور اكيد راح يكون
منز وايضا بدور مساعده راح يكون لانجيلا
بسيط لك
واكيد راح نواجهك بكره بهاي النتائج نتاكد
بالفيلم بس على كل كان جدا رائع يعني وجهه
نظر طيب رافي اليوم مثلا كنا متعودين
دائما مثل هيك ايفان
س المرفت ودائما يعني الممثلين
هاي المره بيش كاربت يعني بس لنفهم ليش
ماخذين بعين الاعتبار انه تضل نظيفه يعني
اول شيء
بتعرفين انت بالفتره الاخيره معظم الجوائز
يعني صاروا يعانون بشكل كبير من التراجع
بالمشاهدات يعني مو بس الاوسكار تراجع
بشكل كبير الجولدن وكل المهرجانات فلهذا
السبب يحاولون يسوون اشياء جديده حتى
يفتونا الانظار يعني اخر مره اتوقع كان
السجاده غير اللون الاحمر كان 1960 اليوم
راح نشوف بيش كارت
مع احمر وبنفس الوقت راح نشوف انه
مغلفه بسبب الامطار
انجز الجو كان غريب عجيب وايضا شفنا في
الاوسكار انه اضافه لجنه لحل الازمات بعد
الصفعه المشهوره اللي صارت
كروس
فحطوا لجنه في حال صار اي مشكله من
المشاكل حتى يحلوها
والشيء الراي اعظم شفنا جيمي كامل يعود
هاي ثالث ماذا يعد بها يقدم بها الاوسكار
السنوات الماضيه شفنا في بعض الاحيان ما
في مقدم ولكن شفنا اليوم راح نشوف ريانا
على المسرح تغني لفت من فيلم بلاك بانثر
فراح يكون حماس بحماس الفتني الاجراءات
اللي عم تحكي عنها في محاوله لاعاده
البريق ان صح التعبير لهذا الحدث
السينمائي الاهم بعد ان فقد بريقه خلال
سنوات الماضيه حدثنا عن المزيد من
الاجراءات رافي اللي تعرفت عليها قبل حفل
الاوسكار لتحفيز المتابعه ومشاهده الافلام
اعتقد اكود تركيز كثير كبير على السوشيال
ميديا انا بسنوات الماضيه كان مستحيل لاي
شخص يفوتوا الاوسكار الا تكون مرشح ولكن
السنه الماضيه شفت موجودين هم رولي
يحاولون انه يعني
يركزون على هاي الفئه يلي حتى يرجعون بريق
هاي المهرجانات انا بالنسبه الي وبراي
الشخصي ايفنتولي المهرجانات سواء كان ساجا
راح يكون
كله راح تنتقل الى المنصات ده تتراجع
مشاهده على التلفزيون ولكن على السوشيال
ميديا بعدها بتتزايد بشكل كبير كبير طيب
برافي كمان بس بدنا نسال شو بيعملوا مثلا
المشاهير اشياء غريبه قبل الحفل لانه مرات
بتكون مثلا النساء بدهم يكونوا بالاكثر
وشو بيعملوا اسرار غريبه وشو الاكل اللي
بقدموه هل فعلا في اشياء غريبه مثلا
بتتقدم للمدعوين اول شيء الفنانين من
الصدق يظلون يمكن جوعانين 24 ساعه يعني
ههه هذا على الاكيد اول ما يفوتون يفوتون
على سجاد الحمراء يلبسون الاحذيه مالتهم
لانه عددا يجي يلبسهم كلش مريح بعدين
يلبسون الحذاء يمشون على الريد كارفور
وبعدين يخلصون يروحون على على المسرح مسرح
الدولبيث تروحون على المسرح دولبي اذا
تشوفون مثلا اذا شخص يريد يروح عفوا مثلا
للحمام يجيبون شخص بديل ممثل لابس البدله
يقعد حتى على الكاميرا ما يبين اكو فراغ
نعم هو هذا الشيء الناس ما يعرفوه بعد ما
يخلص الحفل خلال الحفل ماكو اكل ماكو ولا
شي يعني بعد الحفل يروحون على
بارتي اللي هي
وبعدين شفنا راح نشوف باكر بتقرير راح
يكون شيف يقدم اشياء مو طبيعيه راح يكون
مغطاه
اكيد وبعدها يروحون على
شكرا جزيلا
[ضحك]